armed attackers have killed more than
130 civilians in the west african nation
of burkina faso
authorities believe islamist militants
were behind at the massacre
it took place in the village of solhan
in the north east of the country near
the border with niger
it's the deadliest attack in the country
since islamist violence erupted
in 2015. the fighting has displaced more
than one million people
in burkina faso
and for more on this i am joined by
ornela modaran she's head of the sahel
program at the institute for security
studies that's based in bamako in
neighboring mali thanks so much for
joining us now this is the worst attack
in recent years in burkina faso what
more can you tell us about what happened
in solhan
well we still know very little about the
facts
some of the few facts that we do know is
that
a group of armed assailants attacked
this peaceful civilian village
which is also also um
located near a gold mining site and near
the border with ninja
this is in an area that has been um
exposed to armed violence for
for several years this attack was
particularly brutal in that it made no
difference
uh based on age or sex it attacked men
women
children and the final
death toll that that is reported is
still um
is still temporary so there there is a
possibility that we may end up
with um with a human cost
that's even higher than what we know
already
can you tell us why burkina faso and its
neighbors have seen a resurgence
of extremist violence in recent years
what are these militant groups trying to
achieve
this is a key question i mean um
the entire sahel region is confronted
with a complex security crisis
that dates back to 2012 and the start of
the
crisis in in neighboring mali but over
the years
this crisis has spread to the northern
part of burkina faso where this massacre
happened now as well as
to the western part of niger which has
also been exposed to
large-scale mass attacks against
civilian settlements in the last few
months so
there seems to be a clear attempt by
violent extremist groups to
both scare and push populations away
as well as to confront and undermine
the states in these areas and why
is it proving so difficult to stop the
militant insurgencies in the region
fighting insurgencies in general is
extremely difficult
due to due to the very nature of this
type of of warfare it's extremely mobile
it's extremely volatile
there isn't a specific location
necessary
necessarily where you can identify uh
the the groups and go after them so this
would require in fact
uh state forces taking operational
approaches
that are much more rapid much more
mobile
much more um i mean
using probably smaller units but this
also comes in a much
in a much more complex um
environment where you know issues around
governance local governance around
uh local conflicts who want to compound
uh
the general insecurity and make it even
more
difficult for states which are generally
very centralized and not that
strong in the broader areas to intervene
and effectively protect their
communities
head of the sahel program at the
institute for security studies thanks so
much
you